now that your ant-man and I'm being
serious do you avoid stepping on ants
like when you're outside do you like
respect ants now yeah I mean like a
weird thing happen where it immensely
won't mess with I do feel this kinship
with ants
I was yeah the other day I was like
getting some coffee and a couple of them
were currently from the sink on the way
to the Keurig machine so what do you do
do you like just pick them up and put
them outside if they're if you get ants
on the sound alone I think it like they
found their way in they'll find their
way out wow that's so beautiful
it really is research that much but but
I was shocked to find out that you not
only got the part of it but you wrote
the screenplay with another guy right
well there was you know there's a it I
got this part and this originally
happened because of a guy named Edgar
Wright
wrote the script with another writer and
director guy named Joe Cornish they left
the project Edgar left the movie and
then did they leave because they're
never gonna get this made it's ant-man I
mean what I was supposed to go I think
it was just they had different they had
here Edgar had a different kind of
opinion of what it should be or how even
they work really how they work right
Marvel likes to try lots of different
things and Edgar sticks you know he's
very particular and specific about what
it is they wants to shoot and so you
know some of those conversations went on
kind of without me but it was a pretty
sudden split and then there was another
draft that had been written by somebody
else and then there was this draft that
was kind of floating around we were
gonna shoot it in a few months and so
Adam McKay who wrote and directed
anchorman came onboard because we also
needed a director and then we wound up
writing the writing the script from
there and then eventually I got him
Peyton Reed came on to director and so
were you guys trying to write it as a
comedy well I mean there's nothing
humorous about Ant Man
yeah there's no Wade you've got to play
it straight right you have to play it
straight it has to fit in there and the
thing is like we thought alright people
will think that it's just gonna be a
straight-up comedy which it really
wasn't Marvel
kind of they'd like it to be funny but
then they also wanted to be dramatic and
action and all of that and so is it was
really we were trying to kind of cover
all those bases but at the same time you
know you do tell people ant-man and he's
gonna be flying around on an ant it's
not like we get treated like the most
traumatic thing in the world had you
ever written a script before was this
the first time you actually tackled some
I like that I wrote role models right
and then I also worked on some of the
scripts of this show party down right
and then other things here and there but
as far as an actual credited script this
was I think the third maybe and this is
the studio trust you because role models
made like 92 million dollars or
something so so is that why they trust
you with this franchise honestly I have
no idea why they would write and I don't
I mean what's all surprising and it just
it wasn't pitch them on it I mean do I
have an idea Adam and I Adam and I would
go back like we we would look at we
looked at that script that Edgar had
written right and it never veered that
far from it just as far as the blueprint
of it the kind of his story and then and
then we had some other ideas Adam and I
spent like a couple days talking about
it kind of formulating this and some new
scenes characters and all that stuff
that we went in and talked to them and
said what do you think of this and they
said that's great start writing and so I
wanted to take you to write ant-man
well I always feel like they did really
the heavy lifting so I think that it
probably wound up taking us up a couple
months a couple of months yeah but I'm
going in and out important for an actor
know how to write right in the sense
that now you you know you get you you'll
get better parts because you have that
ability well I think what's nice about
it in my experience when I've done it is
that it you know I really help it helps
me understand the character I know what
the guy would say cuz I you wrote it
yeah when you're gonna play a superhero
and you got to get ripped who do you go
to to get that training I figured if I
get this part Marvel's gonna have their
team and then I don't have to do
anything didn't do any of that have a
teammate I didn't know that yeah there's
no sort of money discuss ahead we're
gonna put you in training camp and we
have a place to send soup right it
started like asking people I knew like
what do you do
so what did you do there I found like I
found a this nutritionist right and also
a guy that like worked with some other
athletes and some actors but the
nutritionists are probably has you do
they have you eat more calories or let's
just gave me a really specific kind of
eating plan like here's what you have
for breakfast he goes here's what you're
gonna have for breakfast you have like
three eggs and some oatmeal and then
also two spoonfuls of this of like
sunflower oil and coconut oil these
natural oils yeah and how do you even
know he knows what he's talking about i
but he's you by the way too good
he was pretty ripped but but I don't
know man maybe was a charlatan Yeah
right